we're going to play a little quiz right
here this is Bronco player or Oscar
winners you got to tell me if this is a
bronco or an Oscar winner okay okay all
right well so you say we'll see okay
Adrien Brody it's an Oscar whoo that's
right Aaron Brewer Blair burt lancaster
dr that's right Vance Walker Oscar and
Walker is a broncos player you got to go
back to the film tape come on man John
Boyd Boyd yes Oscar that's an Oscar
winner Angelina Jolie's dad actually Wow
and what would an actor too right yeah
yeah yeah what's your favorite john-boy
movie oh I can't say don't worry about
it Britton Colquitt Britton Colquitt is
the Denver Bronco right that's right are
you guys buds this oh no no you're not
Jeremy Irons only you are you okay you
guys get to talk to my ex girlfriend all
right is jeremy irons a broncos player
or Oscar winner
hostile one says awesomer ask her how
she's doing like how her life how's your
life going
can't complain Fandango is the best
company in the world man look out for
them I'm going right now to the movies
just because a fan dude you should
probably practice them you should
practice for the Super Bowl right yeah
yeah after break okay